hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna make
a video about whether or not the gods
are real the idea came from a
conversation I had in the comments a
couple weeks ago with a viewer and
something that george RR martin recently
said in an interview before we jump into
it don't forget to stick around to the
end so you can learn about the book
giveaway I have going on now and with
that out of the way let's jump right
into it in a recent video I mentioned
that I thought that gods were just tools
of the major religions in Westeros and
you know beyond into esos they're just
tools that they use to explain this
unknown kind of quality that the magic
in this world has so just to be clear I
do believe there's magic but I don't
necessarily believe that the gods are
responsible for it so as you know
there's tons of religions throughout
this world just like there is in our
world in Westeros the most popular
religion is the faith of the seven which
is a religion that was imported to
Westeros by the Andals when they invaded
members of the faith worship a single
deity that has seven aspects or faces
and it's basically magic less like the
Seven faces or the father the mother the
warrior so on and they're just like
ideals
you know they represents a judgment for
the father motherhood and nurturing for
the mother so they're just sort of like
these ideal principles that are you know
broken up into seven parts the other two
religions that are popular in Westeros
are in the Iron Islands they worship to
drown God and then in the North we know
they worship the old gods now I'm not
going to get into all these different
religions because there are besides
these there are a lot of them and that
could be a whole different video but we
also have a different religion that
follows the Lord of Light role or now
this is going to be the religion I use
for my description here because there is
some very clear magic involved in this
faith which we've seen from a character
who's pretty prominent throughout the
series of course I'm talking about
Melisandre but we'll also talk about a
couple other red priests and priestesses
as we get through this so R allure
is known as the Lord of Light or the
heart of fire and the basic idea behind
this religion is that there's the Lord
of Light and the great other it's
dualistic in that there's a you know a
good God and then there's a bad God I
don't think bad and good are the best
terms we could use here but they're you
know they're opposites let's say that
and one is favorable and the other one
is basically death the great other
exemplifies ice and death so the
conversation started because I had made
that comment about the religions just
basically trying to explain all this
unexplainable magic and the commenter
made a very good point that how could I
say that these religions or gods behind
them weren't real when we see that they
really do stuff mostly from Melisandre
because she does factor into the story
so much george RR martin diffs did a
really long interview I'm sure most of
you have seen it but he recently did a
convention in Mexico where there was a
Q&A period and one of the questions he
was asked was which religion what he
belonged to if he lived in Westeros what
he said was really interesting so I
think I'm gonna mention that and then
we'll get into all that we know about
Melisandre and some of the things that
she's done so george RR martin said that
well you know and i'm gonna paraphrase
obviously but he said well you know we
could look at the faith of the seven
it's the most common religion and when
you join that then you have community
and you're not considered an outsider
and so on and so forth but then he said
you know that we have this faith of a
reward and you know they're pretty cool
because they have actual magic and you
know he goes on to say something to the
effect of i always thought i would join
a religion if they had real magic in the
real world so that's confirmation if we
actually needed it I mean I didn't need
it but just to throw it out there that
there is magic involved with the faith
of relora
so in our story we have a fanatic of
this religion Melisandre is a fanatic
right let's look at what we actually
know she's done when we first meet
Melisandre in the TV show we're not
really sure what to think because she's
doing this whole big thing with Stannis
where she's burning you know the wooden
statues of the seven
and talking about this prophecy and then
she hasn't pulled this flaming sword out
of a fire which seems kind of huckster
ish and in fact it actually is like she
this is just a setup this is really no
magic involved other than making a sword
glow with fire but as time goes on she
starts to do some things that seem
pretty valid especially the shadow baby
like this is indisputable right this is
magic there are a little bit different
in where it happens in the show and the
books but it basically happens the same
way it's not a show only thing I mean
she has a baby that's a shadow and it
goes off and it kills someone right so
at that point you're starting to think
well then you know this woman really is
magical and this God rule or is really
something different than these other
gods we've known before we also know
that Melisandre is much older than she
appears in season six we got this reveal
where she takes off her glamour the ruby
that she wears around her neck and we
see that she's really a whole different
person without it now I'm not gonna go
too deep into this but it just and make
a note that that may not be the only
thing she uses to make her self look
young and attractive there's a scene in
the bathtub where she's not wearing the
ruby and she's talking to Solis which
can be a little bit confusing but she's
also talking about potions and powders
and smokes and things like that so
whether that was misdirection or just a
continuity error you know I don't really
know for sure but I would just say that
she does have magics to conceal her real
identity some other things that she's
done if she's leached the blood of a
king from in the Shogun jury in the
books it was edrick storm but then she
throws those in the fire for the three
kings and eventually all three of them
die this is pretty convincing stuff but
there was a war going on so you could
maybe say that hey these guys would have
died anyways either way it's a pretty
good thing to get Stannis on board and
and I would say any of us would be
hard-pressed to say that she wasn't
magical if we were in her presence the
biggest thing she's done obviously which
hasn't happened in the books yet is she
brought John
no back to life she resurrected his dead
body I think we're gonna get a lot more
details about what happens there but you
know it's important to think about she
didn't even know that this was possible
until she met Thoreau's so it's not
something that she's done in the past or
really even believed in other than what
you know what her fanatical faith would
tell her so again this is definitely
magical the guy was dead there's really
no question it wasn't trickery like you
know the standest thing when she was
burning the statues of the seven so
she's a combination of a trickster who
also has some magic but can we attribute
this magic to the Lord of Light the one
example that I'll get into now is the
shadow baby Melisandre is a religious
fanatic a red priestess of the Lord of
Light but she's also a shadow binder
shadow binding is not related to real or
in any way this is something that she
probably learned in a Shai where she's
from so before she resurrected John this
was her big magical feat but it
shouldn't be confused as something that
people who are red priests or red
priestess can actually do this is
Melisandre specific if you will the one
thing that she does do besides
resurrecting Jon if she sees visions in
the flames
this is a Lord of Light thing there's a
couple problems with this though
sometimes what she sees isn't very clear
and she makes the wrong decisions based
on what she thinks through the filter of
her faith obviously Stannis is still
alive in the books but that doesn't lead
me to believe that he might be as or
high she was just wrong about this in
the show she now believes John is as or
high reborn and in the books there's a
passage where she's looking in the
flames and she wants to see his aura
high and she says all she can see is
snow george RR martin capitalized the
word snow so it leads us to believe that
she's headed that direction there as
well the other problem is there's other
people who get visions in the flames
that directly contradict what she's seen
in the show we saw the were red
priestess Kimbra who believes that
Daenerys is the azure Ahai reborn in the
books there's another guy
mokoro and he's basically the Kimbra
because he believes that Daenerys is the
azure Ahai reborn as well so I'll just
leave you with this and because I'm
gonna have to make this into a two-part
video but if there is a Lord of Light
and he does show his faithful visions in
the flames why would he have different
priests or in this case priestesses see
contradicting visions in part two I'm
gonna go into some theories about that
and I'm gonna talk about some of the
other stuff including the blood magic
and the shadow binding and then we're
gonna figure out whether this is just
magic or if there really is something to
this God reward so a quick update about
my release schedule this weekend before
I get into the book giveaway Saturday
tomorrow we'll have the spoilers video
it's a big one and then Sunday I'll be
doing part two of this video so make
sure that you check back if you haven't
already next to the subscription button
you can click that little bell and
that'll give you a notification whenever
I upload a new video and you won't ever
miss one and one more thing I wanted to
do a shout out for a channel that you
might not have heard of it's called
House MacFarlane he's been putting in
hard work making Game of Thrones videos
and it's trying to grow his subscribers
if you like my channel I think you'll
like his too and I know how hard it can
be to grow a channel so why don't you
guys go over there click on the link at
the top and help him out you can never
really get too much Game of Thrones and
it's always good to support the channels
for people who are making good unique
content and put in real time into it now
for my book giveaway when I reach twenty
eight thousand subscribers I will pick
one person who has commented on the
videos where I mentioned this giveaway
and I will send them the 20th
anniversary edition of a game of Thrones
by George RR martin it's a sweet
Illustrated special edition and I'll put
a link in the description so you can
check it out if you haven't seen it yet
all you have to do is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video or any
of the others where I mention this offer
that's it for now make sure you check in
Saturday for the spoilers and Sunday for
part two when we get into the
of this idea of whether or not the gods
are real thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon